la Coupe du monde de rugby a démarré
depuis ce vendredi en France et ici dans
les Yvelines on vit aussi au rythme de
la Coupe du monde de rugby et notamment
à Croissy-sur-Seine je suis avec son
maire Jean-Roger Davin bonjour bonjour
Alors Jean Roger Davin vous vous avez
une équipe qui va rester le temps des
phases de poules c'est les Tongas alors
déjà comment ça s'est passé un peu le
processus pour attirer cette équipe
c'est quelque chose de très long en fait
c'est déjà une notoriété que nous avons
eu parce qu'on a déjà fait des
championnats d'Europe de football on
avait fait aussi la Coupe du Monde
Féminine de avec la France en cambaz ici
donc on a cette expérience on a un stade
qui est magnifique et après il faut
essayer comme n'importe quel commercial
d'essayer de récupérer une équipe ici
donc on a travaillé de manière très
forte avec France 2023 et puis au fur et
à mesure des rendez-vous au fur et à
mesure des contacts des visites sur le
terrain on a eu deux trois équipes qui
étaient intéressées et on a terminé par
le Tonga qui pour nous était une très
bonne équipe parce que c'est Pacifique
Sud donc avec des gens qui sont
merveilleux et du coup il allait faire
mes sens un petit peu qui monte au sein
de la ville oui bien sûr parce que
d'abord on travaille sur un plan sportif
mais aussi surtout sur un plan culturel
donc les écoles sont bien entendu prises
que ce soit les écoles publiques mais
aussi école municipale de musique la
bibliothèque de chez nous avec leur
décompte et puis de cinéma qui se fait
tout autour et puis bien sûr
l'engouement puisque l'équipe de France
a commencé deux manières victorieuse et
donc ça ne peut que porter l'événement
sur notre ville d'accord il y a quoi
précisément qui a organisé dans dans la
ville par exemple des expositions des
choses comme ça alors vous avez une
exposition sur le rugby qui se passe au
château mais vous avez aussi leur
décompte qui se passait à la
bibliothèque et puis tout ce qui va être
une explication sur le Pacifique
Pacifique Sud que ce soit leur religion
les traditions le sport que l'on fait
avec les enseignants des écoles alors il
y a eu une cérémonie hier qui s'est
déroulée ici à Croissy-sur-Seine avec
l'équipe des tongasques vous pouvez vous
dire un peu comment ça s'est passé alors
c'est là une cérémonie qui a pu
officielle on ne peut absolument déroger
à rien c'est ce se passe dans le rugby
c'est le monde Anglet Saxon donc vous
avez deux grandes parties dans cette
cérémonie une première étape qui est les
discours des officiels donc en fait vous
avez quatre personnes qui parlent le
maire France 2023 la wordre rugby et
puis généralement une autre personne qui
peut-être à un président du Conseil du
Sénat un premier responsable de de
conseil régional et puis ensuite vous
avez la vraie cérémonie officielle ce
qu'on remet les caps comme on dit donc
en fait les casquettes avec une médaille
et ce qui permet à un joueur d'être
identifié comme ayant fait une coupe du
monde de rugby puisque s'ils ne sont pas
dans les trois premiers ils ne recevront
pas une médaille ils pourront montrer
leurs caps et leur médaille de
participation qu'on leur a donné au
départ donc pour très important et très
émouvant c'est la première fois que vous
voyez vous cette équipe de ton gars non
ils sont on les a reçu ici le 5
septembre on les voit régulièrement
s'entraîner sur notre salle mais une
manière officielle ils nous ont fait le
bonheur de nous faire un entraînement
ouvert samedi 9 et puis le la cérémonie
officielle dimanche on va écouter
justement un membre du staff de Tonga
c'est un bon endroit nous aimons
beaucoup
on a déjà eu un super weekend ici et
c'est parfait bon hôtel une belle petite
ville il fait juste un peu chaud
on a tout ce que l'on a besoin on a une
piscine de terrain une salle de sport
une salle de réunion intérieure le
terrain est de classe internationale et
il y avait également beaucoup de
supporters qui étaient présents pour
cette cérémonie et ben plus de 1000
personnes ce qui pour nous est quelque
chose de très important alors
effectivement on aurait peut-être pu en
avoir plus il faisait très très chaud
très très lourd c'est un peu difficile
mais en même temps on se plaint toujours
parce qu'il fait très chaud mais s'il
avait plu il y aurait eu personne donc
dans c'était excellent très très bien
beaucoup d'engouement beaucoup d'enfants
ont fait tout ce qu'il nous faut pour la
ville de Croissy c'est l'occasion aussi
de créer du lien entre une population
étrangère peut-être et des habitants
Croissy-sur-Seine alors vous savez qu'à
Croatie on a plus de 10% de la
population qui est de l'angle
anglo-saxonne mais c'est aussi une coupe
du monde de rugby c'est vous recevez des
jeunes pour recevez des athlètes donc ça
permet à nos jeunes de pouvoir voir non
plus à travers la télé et un écran mais
de visu ce que c'est qu'un sportif de
haut niveau ça permet de décaler et de
montrer à tout le monde que ce qu'elles
sont les valeurs de sport et puis aussi
l'amitié entre les peuples et là de
découvrir un nouveau peuple qui habite
très loin donc il y a Pacifique Sud avec
des traditions comme les maorilles les
walysies donc c'est très important de
pouvoir l'expliquer à nos jeunes le
regard des enfants il était comment hier
en fait c'était pas hier qu'il fallait
venir c'était samedi quand vous étiez
sur le stade avec une équipe qui joue le
jeu une équipe qui donne des maillots
qui a fait bien entendu des interviews
et qui ont donné des signatures donc ça
les enfants étaient très très intéressés
mais un peu avant ils ont fait un
entraînement un vrai entraînement et là
vous voyez la vitesse et laquelle ça va
la nature des chocs et le bruit des
chocs que vous avez entre le rugby donc
en fait vous le voyez sur place quoi on
va écouter justement un supporter qui
était présent sur place hier c'est une
équipe très sympa et avec un qui propose
un beau jeu donc c'est un plaisir
d'aller voir ici quoi je sais qu'il y a
ben qui joue pas à Toulouse
qui joue très très bien aussi ils ont
une belle équipe et je leur souhaite
d'aller plus loin possible du coup c'est
quoi la suite pour cette équipe des
tongs Galles va rester un mois c'est ça
à peu près ici à quoi ça moi d'abord
elle va faire son premier match à Nantes
samedi
alors les Tongas la malchance qu'ils ont
c'est qu'ils sont dans la poule de la
mort
Afrique du Sud Irlande et causes donc ça
c'est dans les cinq premiers mondiaux et
ils sont classés autour de la 15e place
mais pour autant on y croit c'est une
équipe du Sud donc ils sont un peu
fantasques et ils peuvent faire des très
très belles choses d'abord c'est une
équipe de Koso c'est pas des des rigolos
puisque sur 10 coupes du monde ils ont
été présents sur les 8 premières donc
voyez toujours présent à l'appel bon ils
ont fait des bons résultats aussi en
sélection donc il y a pas de raison
qu'on n'est pas une surprise en tout cas
on espère une surprise dans la mesure où
bien entendu il bat pas l'équipe de
France ou qu'on les retrouve en finale
vous avez un petit pronostic ou pas vous
espérez quand même qui passe les poules
j'imagine oui on pense que ça va être
très dur ils ont de fortes chances de
gagner contre la Roumanie peut-être
contre l'Écosse parce qu'on les a vu un
peu en difficulté ce week-end après
l'Irlande et l'Afrique du Sud ça va être
très difficile vous les avez vu un petit
peu à la salle de sport
chez nous et dans notre gymnase beaucoup
bien sûr beaucoup de musculation et
après des phases en action bon là ils
sont en train de répéter leurs gammes
ils font pas vraiment de la muscu c'est
pas la préparation physique dure comme
avant les sélections là ils sont en pro
match donc forcément un peu moins
intense mais surtout dans les tactiques
ils regardent à la vidéo ce qui se passe
dans l'équipe qui vous rencontrez et ils
essaient d'appliquer les techniques et
les tactiques qui vont mettre en place
c'est pour ça que les entraînés les
entraînements sont fermés et qu'on peut
malheureusement pas faire venir plus de
personnes et comment ça va se passer
après pour la suite admettons que les
Tonga soit éliminé à l'issue des phases
de poules comment ça va se passer ici
pour pour la suite alors jusqu'au 4
octobre on a les Tongas il joue leur
dernier match de 7 et ensuite on a été
aussi sélectionné par mes quatre au
centre sur la région Île-de-France pour
pouvoir faire les phases finales donc je
rappelle qu'il y a deux quarts de finale
qui vont se passer au stade de France
les deux demi-finales et les deux
finales perdant et gagnants et donc à
chaque fois on aura la possibilité
d'avoir une des quatre équipes ou des 8
équipes qui seront présentes ici et qui
viendront éventuellement dans notre
salle donc le choix est assez facile
c'est le premier qui choisit son stade
mais je ne je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
dessus en étant à peine à 15-20 minutes
du Stade de France en ayant des
installations sportives et surtout une
pelouse audière de France 2023 qui est
une des meilleures en ce moment donc il
y a pas de problème on aura des gros ici
et on pourra éventuellement si on peut
faire un entraînement ouvert pour
montrer ses équipes au fond de vous vous
aimeriez avoir quelle équipe aucune
elles sont toutes bonnes peut-être les
néo-Z s'ils reviennent alors l'équipe de
France je pense qu'il resteront à Rueil
mais que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud que ce
soit l'Australie que ce soit
l'Angleterre ou le Pays de Galles ou
l'Irlande il y a absolument aucun
problème on va terminer peut-être par un
pronostic pour l'équipe de France sur
l'équipe de France pour ceux qui veulent
aller loin cette équipe de France bah
écoutez ça peut être aussi une belle
fête à quoi c'est sur scène c'est une
victoire on vous l'a pas dit mais on
retransmet tous les matchs à
l'auditorium
mais après poulpe c'est les 5 meilleurs
mondiaux qui sont là donc il va falloir
se retrouver en quart de finale ça ça
devrait pas poser de problème et si on
sort des quarts de finale je pense qu'on
sera champion du monde j'aimerais bien
avoir un match retour entre France
Nouvelle-Zélande avec là aussi encore
une victoire de la France Merci
Jean-Roger Davin et vous l'aurez compris
les Tonga seront ici pendant un mois à
Croissy-sur-Seine